[Musique]
il
quitterie turbide bonjour merci d'être
sur le plateau de tv soixante dix huit
pour ce vip qui vous est entièrement
consacré vous êtes ici parce que vous
êtes yvelinoise vous êtes né à
versailles vous avez vécu longtemps
maintenant vous êtes en suisse bon ça
c'est une autre histoire et vous êtes
surtout ici parce que vous avez une
actualité à savoir une exposition de vos
oeuvres pendant plus d'un mois à paris
on y reviendra tout à l'heure alors
d'abord faisons plus connaissance avec
vous vous êtes artiste plasticienne
savoure on vient comme descriptif
j'ai très bien quelle trace n céramistes
contemporains
quant au port louis et alors vous avez
démarré donc j'avais fait des études
d'art qu'est ce que vous avez fait comme
études
alors j'ai commencé par je suis passé
par les beaux-arts de paris à 18 ans à
peine est en fait les ai quittés pour
faire une école de décors de théâtre et
cinéma alors déjà vous étiez attiré par
le volume non voilà en fait les
beaux-arts faisait uniquement du dessin
de la peinture est en fait le volume des
décors m'a attiré donc j'ai fait quatre
ans une école qui s'appelle l'esat
à paris aussi d'accord donc ça peut
expliquer pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
suffisamment de la peinture à la
sculpture
tout à fait et une fois sculpteur vous
avez comment dire vous avez une idée
assez particulière et vous êtes tourné
vers un public qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
dans le jargon les publics empêchés à
savoir des publics non voyants aveugles
malvoyants et vous avez une idée tout
moment incroyable qu'est ce que vous
avez voulu leur proposait alors enfin
connu un bond en avant qui sont vraiment
directement adressée à ce public j'avais
souvent le désir de mettre en volume des
peintures que
j'aimais beaucoup voilà c'était un peu
des peintres avec souvent des
personnages que j'aimais vraiment sortir
du tableau et l arrière et mettre en
relief en trois dimensions et puis c'est
un ami qui m'a dit mais continuent à
faire ça mais c'est ça pour les non
voyants
donc il m'a juste jeter cette idée comme
ça et puis peu à peu j'ai en fait
construit ce projet j'ai fait des
formations pour quelle formation
alors j'ai fait une déformation en
arrivant en suisse pour des céramiques
afin de maîtriser les techniques sont
quand même très spécifiques
les cuissons les émaux et caetera et
maintenant donc j'ai une technique qui
permet de traduire les lumières dans le
tableau par des émaux différent plus ou
moins lisse plus ou moins là je vais
juste évidemment cantonné au toucher et
axa qui peut être perceptibles pour les
non-voyants dont les jours il valoir
différentes matières et ce serait bien
qu'on envoie à voilà donc l'appareil
dont pouvait nous dire ce qu'on voit
alors là vous avez donc ça c'est une
commande du musée d'art et d'histoire de
genève
c'est le printemps de d'un peintre
suisse qui s'appelle calame
donc on va au dessus là la photo du
tableau original va demander de mettre
en relief donc c'est le paysage que je
suis en train de faire en dessous en
terre donc ça c'est la première étape
pas que c'est un bas relief c'est un bas
relief toutes les oeuvres que vous avez
transcrite en volume le son des balles
on inversait des bas-reliefs moi
j'appelle ça des bailleurs bas-reliefs
on peut dire aussi des maquettes mais en
fait l'intérêt ses excuses j'essaie de
faire une autre oeuvre d'art pour hier
comprendre la peinture
aux gens qui ne la voit pas là alors
comment vous sélectionner les oeuvres
vous dites oh des participants voilà ça
c'est un des premiers que j'ai fait donc
l'autoportrait de van gogh
j'ai sélectionné au départ j'ai voulu
tester un peu tout fou tout les
différents courants picturaux voir ce
qui était le plus intéressant pour les
aveugles
vous avez pris les bruits tenues les
plus connus voilà je suis parti sur les
plus connus parce que c'était quoi le
postulat est et vous vous êtes dit que
finalement ces gens ils sont
complètement exclue d'une certaine
partie de la culture parce que nous
quand on a on nous parle du cri de munch
ou voilà mettons tout de suite ou la
joconde
blake fait là je compte alors là je
compte je voulais pas la fin mais j'ai
demandé à une personne aveugle de
naissance ce qu'ils aimeraient découvrir
et il m'a demandé la joconde en premier
ou qu'en fait je les ai fait d'accord
ben oui c'est ça ce que je voulais vous
demander ses caisses que qu'est-ce qui
appartient à la création collectif et de
quoi sont exclus les aveugles
suffisamment donc c'est les tableaux les
plus connus est plus connu les autres
une fois j'ai entendu à la radio que le
tableau le plus cher c'était le cri de
munch qui avait été vendu un certain
prix donc je me suis dit voilà un
envoyant en temps ça il faut donc j'ai
fait le cri de munch d'accord et alors
quels sont les justement les non voyants
qu'est-ce qui vous disent une fois
qu'ils ont touché vovo vos oeuvres
alors en fait ça dépend vraiment de la
deûle à faire si la personne a vu si
elle a perdu 9 images in auquel n'ai
jamais vu que ce soit même gêné sont
alors elle perçoit elle arrive à se
rendre compte de la composition du
tableau des dés de l'échelle de grandeur
perspective c'est possible la
perspective c'est très compliqué pour un
envoyant de comprendre ce que c'est que
la perspective c'est d'être très
compliqué aussi à reproduise
alors par exemple sur le cri de munch en
effet ya la balustrade et yann point de
fuite comme ça à reproduire c'est pas
spécialement dur mais de comprendre ça
quand on n'a jamais vu c'est vraiment
très donc tout n'est pas forcément
transmissibles
ça c'est un dernier tableau que j'ai
fait justement que jamais besoin c'est
un tableaux symbolistes cela vague de
choix bassin peintre suisse et donc il
ya cette femme alors celui-ci est
intéressant parce que c'est un tableau
qui est très foncé qu'à plein de couches
de vernis soul et qu'elle disparaisse la
peinture est en fait moi j'ai besoin
d'éclaircir énormément ce tableau pour
le travail et sur l'ordinateur je mets
vraiment beaucoup de saturation et j'ai
aperçu s'est drapé que qui recouvre les
femmes c'est une vague une vague
les femmes sont recouverts d'écumé à des
drapés on voit uniquement en
éclaircissant le tableau donc on ne va
pas nous veillons donc là le rôle est un
peu averse un excellent ça les
non-voyants vont pouvoir toucher cpie
que nous ne voyons pas c'est pour ça que
dit l'aveuglent parfois touche que le
nous ne voyons pas voilà où alors c'est
des petits détails que je suis a été
happée excusez moi c'est l'émotion
alors oui teese est aveugle ou à toi
forcément et puis en moi j'ai comme
j'agrandis tous énormément il ya des
petites choses que je vois donc je mets
en avant
et voilà donc le c'est le monde à
l'envers pas toujours vous avez un petit
peu mais c'est un peu ce que c'est
plutôt sympathique et alors donc vous
disiez est ce que vous arrivez à
traduire par exemple les différents
matériaux jeudi de l'huile le pastel
l'aquarelle
comment on fait alors par exemple si
évidemment c'est le
une femme aux bains de garons nécessite
un pastel donc j'ai essayé de jouer avec
la matière de faire dégriffer est
toujours de jouer avec les émaux mais il
faut toujours que ce soit agréable a
touché bien sûrement oui je dois
toujours être limite entre quelque chose
de très rugueux et ça prend quand même
qui donne une idée de la matière mais
voilà on ait envie de dénoncer le
travail les magnifiques il donc en
suisse c'est très apprécié apparemment
vous travaillez donc avec le musée d'art
et d'histoire de genève voilà alors avec
la sec ont les musées rhodes
voilà position sur aude l'air j'avais
une salle entièrement consacré à ses
bas-reliefs on avait enfin le alors
voici 5 vous avez une deuxième partie
dans votre carrière c'est cette
exposition là qui va avoir lieu très
bientôt vous êtes exposé une galerie à
peindre à paris c'est que ce sont des
céramiques là qui n'ont plus rien à voir
voilà encore pas quel est ce qui est un
thème non il n'y a pas de thème est là
c'est un travail je me laisse
complètement aller là on peut voir un
s'appelle la colonne sur varane c'est un
mouton inspiré de la news di2 urban que
j'ai remis droit en fait il a les pattes
ficelé way et il tourne sur un soc un
peu comme un kebab sursaut est surtout
consacré ferrière d'accord il ya
d'autres oeuvres on va voir défiler
plusieurs vous est alors ça c'est un peu
versailles c'est complètement versa
c'est le bassin de neptune qui des
éléments d'une fontaine avec louis xiv
et marie thérèse qui sont dans prennent
un bain tu prennes abbas une sorte de
manège sur le bassin de neptune
voilà il ya des jambes des mains des
tasses en porcelaine
quand on vous dit le mot grotesque ce
que je sais que vous avez participé à
une exposition dont le thème était le
grotesque d'ailleurs tout à fait ça ça
vous parle pas plus que ça grotesque ça
veut dire quoi non alors gros test que
ça vient des grottes en fait avant il y
avait des bonbons à lorient nancy c'est
l'ornementation le foisonnement les dons
qu'il ya haute et du surveillant tout
vat cher là qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est
un lacet des sucettes au parfum de louis
xiv et de marie thérèse et dans cette
exposition il y aura des nouveaux
parfums il y aura un parfum de géniale
idée le parfum mireille mathieu
commensal parfum c'est des glaces ou des
sucettes avec des parfums différents
selon les personnages trêve de femme de
johnny pourront acquérir une fiche est
au parfum de chauny formidable et on les
voit pas là là on a le nord parce
qu'elles sont vraiment toutes récentes
elles sortent du four donc il faudra pas
aller les voir donc cette galerie
s'appelle comment s'appelle 70 verbois
78 du vert bois
voilà c'était un cabinet d'amateur c'est
christophe et gilles qui ont ouvert cet
endroit qui est superbe c'est quoi un
charnier d'amateurs c'est un endroit en
fait ils ont voulu se différencier un
peu d'une galerie et qui était un peu
froid et protocolaire donc là en fait en
même temps il aime beaucoup chine est ok
des très beaux objets et par moments ils
font en plein feu sur un artiste c'est
ce mois sont plus des objets permanent
voilà donc ça fonctionne un peu comme un
cabinet de curiosités on peut dire aussi
c'est un petit peu ça oui là c'est là
leur colonne batman que vous pouvez voir
sur les locaux nous avons batman est en
face batmag des chauves souris des
monde un peu vésuve à un ami voilà
d'accord oui donc là effectivement c'est
rigolo parce que d'une part votre
travail de bas relief pour les non
voyants
c'est vraiment on est dans la
reproduction au plus fidèles même si
c'est une création pure
hélas une exubérance total tout est
permis
basée comme ça que je trouve mon
équilibre finalement entre quelque chose
de très cadré ouais je très fidèle et
puis là je peux me laisser complètement
aller et le très cadré ça vous plaît
aussi
oui ça me plaît aussi c'est une
gymnastique de l'esprit de passer à la
2d de la 2d à la 3d et la ouvre un
gâteau d'anniversaire alors pas tout à
fait c'est la colonne à saragosa en les
vieilles adrets bougies en porcelaine cd
churros et après un voyage en espagne un
accès des robes des ménines de vélasquez
on voit même philippe iv à l'intérieur
avec sa fille marie thérèse que je
travaillais quand elle était jeune et
qu'on retrouve dans le château de vayres
dans le bassin de neptune
c'est la même c'est amusant car oui les
mecs donc en fait votre enfance versez y
est vous vous hante encore quelque part
ben c'est sûr elle va juste complètement
ça a été toute ma toute ma richesse
finalement une partie il veut tuer
l'iphone parti voilà est donc en suisse
l'accueil l'accueil et comment rapport à
vos oeuvres par rapport aux oeuvres pour
les aveugles
ouais bah ça c'est en fait le seul musée
qui m'ont ouvert la porte
leurs portes et qui vont mettre en
permanence
certains des bas-reliefs à côté des
tableaux donc pour tout le monde
finalement
pour tous le maître que tout le monde a
envie de toucher la voie à tableau les
enfants les ados voilà on est qu'est-ce
qui vous disent les enfants par exemple
les enfants je les fréquente pas à pau
qui me dire ça mais en fait oui ils
intéressés que ce soit un travail que
c'est un travail qui attire tout le
monde ça attire tout le monde voilà
enfin prière de toucher plus tôt que ne
pas toucher l'air génial m'écouter à
grand merci
c'est une des options mot formidable
kiki donc touche tout le monde ce
qu'elle veut dire et on ira voir vos
oeuvres complètement hurluberlus est-ce
qu au cabinet que j'étais de christophe
et gilles là dans le troisième dans le
troisième mais savoir qui vous remercie
véronique et ainsi d'être venus de si
loin qu'il restait un petit peu à
versailles avec plaisir merci merci de
m'avoir quitterais une fois
[Musique]